So far, there are a lot of
ways to clone genes.
I've given you two.
Later in the course, I'll give
you a third, but we cloned it
here by its function,
complementation.
We cloned it here on
the basis of the
protein it actually made.
Now, how do we analyze
these genes?
How do you know which gene
we're dealing with?
How do we study it?
Let's turn to that.
Analyzing our gene.
Well, let's suppose we
have our cell, maybe
it's our yeast cell.
It's Arg1 again.
We'll go back to yeast.
It's got its yeast DNA it's also
got this circle that has
our plasmid here.
Circle is plasmid.
How are we going to
study that gene?
We know that yeast is
able to now grow.
We can grow up that yeast.
We can purify DNA from it.
But wait a second.
How do we get our plasmids away
from the chromosomal DNA?
Aren't we back in the same
boat of you can't
purify DNA from DNA?
Thankfully, this is easy.
Little circles of DNA have
different biochemical
properties than the long, linear
chromosomes or the big
chunks of DNA.
And you can use biochemistry to
separate little circles of
DNA from big chunks of DNA.
So no problem.
You can purify the plasmids.
Purify the plasmid,
and there it is.
It's back again.
And now, you've got
your Arg1 gene.
How do I study it?
Well, the first thing I might
want to find out about my Arg1
gene, is how big
is that insert.
How can I find out how
big that insert is?
AUDIENCE: Electrophoresis.
ERIC LANDER: Electrophoresis.
I first have to cut
out the insert.
How do I do that?
AUDIENCE: The restriction
enzyme.
ERIC LANDER: My restriction
enzyme, EcoRI.
I cut with EcoRI and it
liberates the insert.
And then I take a gel, which can
be made out of different
substances, and I put
my DNA there.
Agarose is particularly nice
stuff, which is basically
Jell-O. And I turn on
an electric field.
DNA is what, positively charged
or negatively charged?
AUDIENCE: Negative.
ERIC LANDER: So what kind of
charge do I want to put here?
AUDIENCE: Positive.
ERIC LANDER: What charge
do I put here?
AUDIENCE: Negative.
ERIC LANDER: What happens
if I do it backwards?
Bad.
Everybody does it backwards
in the lab at some point.
So then you do this.
The DNA goes this way and it
turns out that agarose is this
matrix of cross links
and all that.
And DNA molecules wiggle through
like a snake, through
this matrix, and little ones go
much faster than big ones.
So what happens is, little DNA
molecules move faster than big
DNA molecules.
And if I stop at some point, and
I add a dye that sticks to
DNA, and look at it with a
fluorescent light, I can
actually see where the
DNA molecules are.
So I've grown up a ton of this
plasmid, lots of it, couple of
micrograms of it.
I cut it, I add it to the top of
my well here, I turn on the
electricity, and it wiggle,
wiggle, wiggles through.
This is the vector, and
this is the insert.
It might be actually, that I
found another plasmid that
could do this too, that
rescued yeast.
It had a vector and maybe
at a different insert.
Maybe I had one, I don't know
why, that had the same insert
right there.
In any case, the first
characterization that I would
do is look at the size
of my insert.
How big is that insert?
I might find out that the insert
is one kilobase, 1,000
bases, or one KB, or 2 KB
or something like that.
That's a first order of
characterization.
Now, of course, what I
really want to know
about the insert, sequence.
I want the DNA sequencing
insert, right?
Let's not just mess around with,
it's got 1,000 bases, I
want to know what are those
bases in what order.
So that means I have to
invent DNA sequencing.
All right.
So how am I going to invent
DNA sequencing?
This is a little tough.
I have my piece of DNA.
I cut it out.
Here's my piece of DNA,
5 prime to 3 prime,
5 prime to 3 prime.
Let's give it a sequence
ATTAAGAATGCAT, et cetera.
DNA sequencing is actually
remarkably cute.
I take a primer just like
Kornberg did back when he was
discovering polymerase.
Here's my primer, let's say.
Here's my primer.
Here's the matching template.
And what did Kornberg
teaches us?
He taught us that if we add
polymerase, what will
polymerase do?
It'll add the right
bases, right?
TACGTA onward.
If we could look really fast,
maybe we could just
see it going by.
But we can't look really fast.
If we just add polymerase,
it'll just zip up
and add all the bases.
But someone had a
clever trick.
The clever trick is this.
Suppose I threw in a smidgen
of defective Ts, Ts that
couldn't be extended
for some reason?
I'll call that T star.
What happens if a defective
T goes in there?
Can't be extended anymore.
And what happens then
to my reaction?
It comes to a halt.
Ah, but what happened if
I put in a good T?
Then instead, what would
the next base be?
A. Then what would happen?
C, G. Then what's next?
T. And what would happen if
I put in a defective T?
It would stop.
Now, maybe instead the defective
T didn't go in.
And it would go on, and the
next T that it encounters,
maybe it would put a
defective T there.
Or maybe it would put
a defective T there.
Now, of course, I just have
a little smidgen of
defective T, right?
So which of these will happen?
Will it sometimes stop
at the first T?
Sometimes at the second?
Sometimes at the third?
I'll actually get a series
of molecules.
What will the lengths of those
molecules tell me?
Where the Ts are.
Kind of cute.
This is very cute.
So if I do that reaction, I'll
call that the defective Ts, I
could see that there is some
molecules, stop here at this
very small size, some stop here,
some stop here, some
stop there, some stop there.
And what have I just learned?
The sizes, the lengths of the
fragments that end in T.
But that's not good.
I also want to know the As.
AUDIENCE: Do it with
defective As.
ERIC LANDER: Do it will
defective As, right?
I'll just use defective As.
And then I'll see the
As stop there.
And then I'll do it with
defective Cs, and I'll do it
with defective Gs.
And I'll see exactly where the
molecules are, the lengths of
the molecules that end
in A, T, C, and G.
And I've just read the
sequence, haven't I?
Pretty cool.
This actually is so cool,
it won a Nobel Prize.
I mean cool usually means won
a Nobel Prize or something
like that in this class.
So actually, how do
I visualize the
little letters there?
So the little fragments
on the gel?
I visualize the little
fragments back in
ancient days, yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you
know [INAUDIBLE]
necessarily be inserted
in every place
where there is a letter?
ERIC LANDER: I'd make
the right ratio.
I'd choose a ratio of defective
to good Ts.
Like if I choose 1% defective
T's, then about 1% of the
time, I put in the defective
T it turns out.
It turns out to work OK.
I just put in a smidgen of
defective Ts, like 1%, and 1%
of the time it stops here, and
1% here, and 1% there.
So and then, of course, to see
them in old days, what people
did was they made these primers
radioactive, and these
radioactive primers here within
the gel would be held
up against a piece of x-ray
film, and you would see where
little radioactive bands were.
That's how you could visualize
the primers, because it turns
out you have too little primer
to see it even with my
fluorescent dye.
But a little radioactivity,
you add radioactivity, you
take the gel off, you put on a
piece of, I guess you've got
to wrap it with Saran.
You'd better be standing
behind a shield.
So you're standing behind a
plastic shield, you reach
around the shield, you wrap
it with Saran Wrap.
You then put x-ray film on.
You are you doing this
in a dark room.
You then seal it up.
You put it in the freezer
for two weeks.
You take it out.
You develop it.
You get your magic marker, and
you follow where all the
little bands are.
And that's DNA sequencing.
It's cool.
It won a Nobel Prize.
It's also like really tedious.
So little tricks were done to
speed it up, some nice pieces
of engineering.
Instead of visualizing our DNA,
faster DNA sequencing,
what happens instead?
What people did, which was very
cool, was they simply
took the As, Ts, Cs and Gs,
the defective ones, they
attached a colored
dye to each one.
The As were green, and the Ts
were blue and the Gs were red.
Now, when I run it out, I can
do it with fluorescence.
And I can see the Ts all glow
one color, and the As glow
another color.
Now, it turns out, of course,
if they're glowing four
different colors, I don't
actually need to run them in
separate lanes.
I could run them in the
same lane, right?
So I could run them all in a
single lane, and I'd see Ts
and As, and Gs.
And now, instead of putting this
up against the piece of
x-ray film, I could do
this in a very thin
tube called a capillary.
And instead of holding it up to
an x-ray film, I could just
put a laser detector.
I can turn on the electricity
and watch the fragments go by
and just look at it with
my laser detector.
Shines a light.
I say, oh yeah, green,
red, blue.
That's the sequence.
This made it a lot
easier than that.
I actually got involved in
molecular biology when it was
still that.
That is a lot better.
By the way, I didn't tell
you what the defective
Ts were, did I?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC LANDER: Sorry?
ERIC LANDER: Well, they gotta
have something that prevents
them from being extended,
right?
What prevents them from
being extended?
Do we remember how
DNA is extended?
We have a sugar phosphate
backbone, right?
Phosphate, base, 5 prime.
Where do we extend, what base?
3 prime.
And what do we use
to extend on?
The 3 prime hydroxyl.
Remember, DNA has no hydroxyl
at its 2 prime position.
Its normal DNA is
2 prime deoxy.
How do you think we prevent
it from being extended?
AUDIENCE: 2 prime [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC LANDER: 2 prime,
3 prime dideoxy.
Defective just means 2 prime,
See, we tell you about these
structure not just so you
memorize structures, but because
those are the tricks
we use in the trade.
Now, you get yourself some 2
prime, 3 prime dideoxies.
You put in a smidgen,
maybe 1%.
You run your reaction.
Those dideoxies have dyes,
spelled differently, D-Y-E
color dyes attached to them.
And you sit there with
your laser detector.
Turns out to be even better.
If you have one capillary,
you could have two.
If you have two, you could have
three, and the machines
that were built around 1999
had 96 capillaries.
I'll call it 100.
You could sit there and read
700 bases every hour.
You can do this maybe
20 hours in the day
because it's automated.
You could do this
360 days a year.
And at MIT, we had 100 machines
during the Human
Genome Project.
And if you do the arithmetic, we
could read about 60 billion
bases a year, 60 billion bases
a year during the height of
the Human Genome Project.
Now, this is pretty cool, but
it ain't nothing compared to
what we're doing
10 years later.
Currently, we are doing
60 billion bases every
10 minutes at MIT.
There's a little trick that I'll
tell you about next time
of how DNA sequencing went from
that, where you could do
about 250 letters a day, when I
first got involved in this,
to that, where at a large
facility like MIT, you could
do 60 billion letters a day, to
today when you can do about
60 billion letters
in 10 minutes.
We'll touch on that next time.